OKAY GOOD MORNING.
.
MEMBERS WERE HERE THE JOBS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE ONE BILL WE
WANT TO WELCOME YOU AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO ASK OUR AUTHOR TO
PRESENT. A WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU GIVE ME JUST ONE
SECOND HERE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN SIX UNTIL A BILL THAT
WOULD SUPPORT BUSINESSES THAT
HELP UPLIFT OTHER TO SERVING.
AND OFTEN MARGINALIZED RESIDENTS
I WANNA THINK THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH ME
AND THE SPONSOR. AND MY OFFICE
AND CLARIFYING THE INTENT OF OUR
BILL. AS WELL AS FOR THEIR
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AS TO WHY AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO IS
NEEDED.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ARE AS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY SIX A TO MAKE THE
FERRY UPDATES TO STATE LAW TO
INCLUDE CONTRACTING PREFERENCES
FOR DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES.
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS ENTERPRISES
AND SOCIAL ENTERPRISES BY
INCREASING. BIDDING PREFERENCES
FOR PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTS.
DOING SO WILL HELP LOCAL
BUSINESSES GROW THEIR WORKFORCE
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY. EMPLOY
THOSE WHO FACE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE THEY SUFFER
FROM DISABILITIES HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED ARE HOMELESS. OR
YOUTH HAD BEEN DISCONNECTED FROM
SCHOOL OR WORK.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
FACING FORMER BALL. CHALLENGES
IN SUPPORTING ECONOMIC STABILITY
AND SECURITY AMONG OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY
ALLOWING CONTRACT PREFERENCES
FOR DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
ON LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES. WILL STIMULATE
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND EXPAND
APPOINTMENT PROSPECTS FOR HARD
TO EMPLOY. INDIVIDUALS
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS JOEL
AYE AYE AYE GALA CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS. AND STEVEN
NORRIS FROM JUMA A SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS UNTIL A ALLEN
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I AM THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE.
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS ON A THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
WITH YOU THIS MORNING AT ABOUT
THE COUNTY SPONSORED AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO WHICH WOULD.
PROMOTE GREATER INCLUSION AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESS BUSINESSES AND SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES AND LOCAL AGENCY
CONTRACTING ACTIVITIES.
SPECIFICALLY AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO WHAT AMEND THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE. TO EXPAND
PREFERENCE ALLOWANCES TO INCLUDE
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES AND
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES AS WELL AS
INCREASE THE PREFERENCE
PERCENTAGE.
AND WOULD APPLY TO CONSTRUCTION.
OR COMMIT OF GOODS OR DELIVERY
OF SERVICES.
CURRENTLY THE PCC LIMITS
PREFERENCE ALLOWANCES.
TO SMALL BUSINESSES ONLY AND FOR
AN AMOUNT UP TO FIVE PERCENT.
YOU TO EXISTS EXISTING
LIMITATIONS ON LA. THE COUNTY IS
PRECLUDED FROM GRANTING
PREFERENCES TO DEAN DE DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESSES AND SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES FOR CERTAIN LOW BED
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ADOPTED ITS
SMALL BUSINESS DISABLED VETERAN
HAS SOME BUSINESS AND SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE UTILIZATION PLAN.
TO PROMOTE AND FACILITATE
BUSINESSES THAT DISTINGUISH
THEMSELVES BY PROMOTING A
POSITIVE SOCIAL. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
AS PART OF THIS EFFORT THE BOARD
ADOPTED AN ORDINANCE TO ALLOW.
CONTRACT PREFERENCES FOR
QUALIFIED LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES DISABLED
VETERANS. BUSINESSES AND SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES. UNLESS OTHERWISE
REQUIRED UNLESS OTHERWISE
REQUIRED BY LAW.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO WAS
CREATED TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO
INCLUDE.
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES AND
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES AND
PREFERENCE ALLOWANCES UNDER
STATE LAW AND TO INCREASE THE
PREFERENCE AMOUNT. ALLOWED IN
ORDER TO ENHANCE AND EXPAND
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THESE BUSINESSES BECAUSE
BENEFITS THAT.
WHOSE WORK BENEFITS THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY.
IN CLOSING. AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO WAS THAT WAS DESIGNED
TO BE INCLUSIVE AND PROVIDE
LOCAL AGENCIES THE OPTION OF
EXPANDING PARTICIPATION.
AND LOCAL AGENCY CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES.
AND FOR THOSE LOCAL BUSINESSES
WHICH SERVE TO STIMULATE LOCAL
ECONOMIC GROWTH. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY CAN ENHANCE THEIR
ABILITY TO BUILD THEIR WORKFORCE
INCLUDING. EMPLOYING THOSE.
THOSE WHO FACE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S EFFORTS ANTICS BANG
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
QUALIFIED LOCAL BUSINESSES AND
KINDLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I NEXT.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AT MY NAME IS STEVEN
NORRIS AND I AM THE SACRAMENTO
SITE DIRECTOR OF JIMMA. A
NONPROFIT SOCIAL ENTERPRISE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT IT
BE TWO SEVEN SIX TWO.
WE OPERATE SOCIAL ENTERPRISES IN
SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND
AND SAN JOSE.
HIRING LOW INCOME IN
DISCONNECTED OPPORTUNITY USED TO
GIVE THEM THE EARNINGS SKILLS
AND EXPERIENCE THEY NEED. AND
ULTIMATELY CONNECT THEM TO THE
NEXT STEP TOWARDS THEIR CAREER.
JIM WAS MISSION IS TO BREAK THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY BY PAVING THE
WAY TO WORK EDUCATION AND
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY. FOR YOUTH.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP YOU MISSUS
STAND EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR MISSION.
THANK YOU PROCEED THAT THANK YOU
CAN YOU JUST REPEAT IS IT.
THE THE NAME OF JULY J. UIMA
JUBA. YEAH ALRIGHT THANK YOU. HA
ALRIGHT DOES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING.
MICHAEL CHANG WITH A CALIFORNIA
IS IN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT.
Q. ANYBODY ELSE.
ALRIGHT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
OF THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
FACING NINE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO OUR COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM ARE SIMPLY
MEMBERS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SHARE THAT
I SUPPORT THIS BILL I'VE COMING
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THEY KNOW
THEY'RE COMING NEED US THEY KNOW
WHO'S WHO NEEDS TO BE SERVED AND
OF COURSE WE KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO TO. PUSH
FORWARD US SUPPORT FOR DISABLED
AND SOCIAL ENTERPRISES IS GOING
TO MAKE THAT DIFFERENCE IN THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE IT A GREAT
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO SEE OUR COMMUNITIES
THRIVING. SO WITH THAT A WEEK
WEEK LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL
PROCOL
MISTER SECRETARY.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
HERE.
SURE QUIRK SILVA THE HERE.
PLACE YOUR ALLEN.
BERMAN.
BERMAN HERE.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES HERE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER PER HERE.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE.
BUT I'M SURE WE HAVE QUORUM.
ALRIGHT THERE WE ARE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND.
TAKE A. VOTE ON THIS
IN.
AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION
BY MISTER BARONE MEN AND SECOND
BY SOME AMERICAN SOLIS AND TAKE
THE ROLE MISTER SECRETARY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
I.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I.
UP YOUR BILL IS OUT AND THAT
WILL BE REFERRED TO. BREAK UP
FLOOR RIGHT TO THE FLOOR
CONGRATULATIONS AND HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND EVERYBODY